I really think that John and I and the
rest of the production team at the
outset recognized the enormous task that
we would have in trying to make a movie
based on something that's treasured by
so many people we kind of note what did
it say said who is John Galt my name is
Harmon Kaslo I am the producer of Atlas
Shrugged with John egli Laura I Taggart
transcontinental freight train has
crashed and derailed well this movie is
based on the first part of the book
about the character development of Atlas
Shrugged the people that I am put in her
story to describe her philosophy but
this movie i think really comes across
as a very empowering movie for women
it's about about a woman who takes on a
lot of forces working against her I'm
not going to lie it around that time you
can do whatever you want with your men
mr. Brady but that train will run if I
have to drive the damn thing myself and
it really sets a good foundation for the
balance of the book where it gets into
more of the political and philosophical
content that that people really obscure
I've to when they think of the book out
of shrugged what is wrong with the world
who is John Galt I want to tell Dagny
story and I have to introduce her world
my name is Brian O'Toole and I'm the
screenwriter on Atlas Shrugged part 1 it
broke down the first part and I tried to
find the basis of it some skeleton and
so to me this was the underdog story
nobody she was Rearden metal why do we
have to be first it's a story of dagny
taggart who just discovered there's been
a major wreck on one of her lines and it
was actually to Ellis Wyatt the last
supplier of oil in the country and
because of their incompetents or her
brothers and competence he's now going
with a competing line find a way to fix
this you and your brother try to
undermine or go to the government maybe
you should let me examine you should
like me finish speaking and her job now
is to save that company by getting that
line fixed so she goes outside the box
and she finds somebody who's created a
new metal something that's stronger than
steel lighter than steel cheaper than
steel even though everyone around her is
telling you you can't use it it's not
proven she steps up and she says no I'm
gonna use it and I'm gambling
and do what you say it can I'm staking
my business on and so she decides along
with hank rearden in order to save my
company my family business I'm gonna
have to abandon I'm gonna take a leap we
start my own company which pisses off
everybody that's been against them all
along if we're gonna bring Reardon down
we should do it from the inside the
whole theme of the story is really human
evil if you double-crossed me I will
destroy you and human evil spawns from
good intentions I mean the government
isn't isn't malicious they think what
they're doing is right the federal tax
will be applied to all steel mills they
don't realize their consequences they
are not getting my metal that's human
evil and that to me was what the
government in this book was doing that's
the theme that I'm going to take through
the whole story all three parts
you